it is April 20th today marijuana users
might know it better though as 420. the
Nevada legislature just voted in support
of descheduling cannabis federally
because his eight news now reporter Ryan
Matthey explains experts say it's
preventing the industry from growing
further in 2016 Nevada voters gave the
green light to recreational cannabis use
it's led to a hundred dispensaries
opening up across the state but opening
any more has its own complications this
brand was created by one of my very best
friends MJ Jamison opened Tree of Life a
year ago a self-proclaimed mom-and-pop
dispensary he founded a dispensary
literally for the sole purpose of giving
back in just a year she says they've
raised a hundred and forty thousand
dollars to donate to local charities
like volunteers for medicine the
Salvation Army and the lgbtq center of
Southern Nevada it's not going away it
continues to grow a budding industry
with growing rewards the Nevada
Department of Taxation reported it over
150 million in tax revenue last fiscal
year and so far this fiscal year it's
already over 77 million sales in total
reaching nearly a billion dollars
Statewide in 2022 bringing a demand for
more trained workers green flower a
cannabis education company started
teaching courses at CSN this year on
average most jobs in the Cannabis
industry are paying about 20 more than
than similar counterparts we do have
very significant obstacles ahead
obstacles that Lake Martin executive
director of the Nevada cannabis
Association says lies both at the state
and federal levels locally with illegal
and unlicensed businesses operating in
the shadows not only hinders the growth
of the licensed cannabis industry but
it's diverting tax revenue away from the
state and federally the scheduling of
the drug which is still the same level
as heroin it prevents the import or
export of cannabis products outside of
the state and requires the higher fees
to support regulation so these are all
issues that could be addressed through
descheduling